one of the easiest ways to stay healthy
is to schedule a once a year visit with
your doctor here to tell us more is dr
troy bertoli from p3 medical group who
are sponsoring this segment welcome to
the show thank you thanks for having me
so why is an annual important annual
visit so important
well we kind of consider the annual
visit one of the most important visits
uh for the patient and for us
we kind of get to know you we want to
update your any medical conditions you
have uh review your list of medications
or the right stuff do we need to bring
some off do we need to add anything new
and then do some testing to find out
what you're at risk for and why should
we schedule these appointments
just because of that right so um you
know i kind of look at things our job is
to try to find out what's going to hurt
you along the way and put it off as long
as we can
and that be what blood pressure or
fall risk for some patients or uh
they're on the wrong medicines or you
know depression and all kinds of
screenings which we do in our annual
visit so let's break it down someone
comes into their visit what can they
expect during their visit
they can expect um they come in like a
regular doctor's visit we'll check their
vitals and uh
and then
talk to them about okay any new medical
conditions maybe they've seen some
specialists through the years through
the year and then we'll uh update those
things
and
see if there's any other testing we need
to do
and go just go
further with that and then there's some
other testing for uh you know fall risks
and
and uh memory issues and
just general all around and
you know getting a baseline is important
right so trying to find out what your
baseline is now so maybe we do this next
year or the year after that and maybe
they're not so good and we look back
well you used to be this way so is there
some kind of intervention with there's
something changing we can slow that down
is there is is there certain age when
someone should start getting
an annual visit because we did here in
the studio just a quick poll and and one
out of three of us goes annually to
their doctor at what age where should
you always be going is there a certain
age that this is the age to start coming
in and getting that annual visit done a
lot of that's considered your medical
history you know and um
your lifestyle is a big thing fine right
your diet exercise and and uh what
happened along the way and what your
history is and your family history okay
now someone is coming in for the visit
how should they prepare for for their
visit
bringing a list of medications is very
important
um bringing any
if you're new to that office and you
haven't been seen there before we might
want to want any pertinent medical
information you have like what other
doctors am i seeing uh where's my
previous practice a lot of people move
here from vegas where were you before so
we can kind of request those records and
have your history to go along with that
where can someone watching get a
comprehensive visit
any of our p3 medical offices
for one but your primary care provider
okay now what else does p3 partners
provide you guys do many services what
else do you guys provide well we've got
10 offices around the valley um and
we've got
close to 350
including affiliates
primary providers
close to a thousand
specialists that we work with closely
but
primary office and management of care
awesome dr troy you covered it all we
appreciate it buddy thank you thanks for
joining us today and thank you to our
sponsor p3 medical group you can call
them at 702 333
or visit them at their website they're
on the screen p3 mg.org las vegas now we
will be right back